[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la nueva estrategia de
guerra de los rusos contra ucrania la
segunda fase de la ofensiva como la
denominaron desde el kremlin consiste en
liberar completamente la región del
donbass en el este ucraniano y hacerse
con el control de mariupol que permanece
cercado por las tropas rusas para al
final lograr un corredor por el sur
desde crimea pero además recientes
ataques en la región separatista de
transnistria alertan a las autoridades
de moldavia
para ello entonces quiero saludar a
pablo hernández analista especializado
en historia de rusia también historia
militar y docente de la universidad
interamericana gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
pablo y le quiero preguntar entonces la
importancia de mariupol porque la
quieren tomar los rusos
bueno buenos días marie paule es la
conexión entre el norte de crimea osea
la franja terrestre que está entre el
dniéper crimea y la conexión con el
donbass es la manera de establecer un
corredor seguro
para unir la zona separatista
con la zona ocupada que hasta entonces
estaba en mano usted sabe que había una
franja de tierra verde ans
mérito por mario pool que era una
barrera entre los separatistas del dogma
y su fuerza rusa y la zona ocupada del
abismo del precop ii es una conexión
perfecta entre crimea que es un
verdadero arsenal militar y los aliados
russo del oriente al establecer esa
conexión
probablemente con una presión que se
haga del norte de la dirección de arco
iris o y por el sur hacia esa por ex ya
se puede tratar de hacer una
un movimiento envolvente y capturar en
una bolsa las fuerzas ucranianas las
mejores fuerzas ucranianas hasta que
están sosteniendo el frente del donbass
como una maniobra
que quizás sea si uno estudia un poco
históricamente lo que hicieron los rusos
en la segunda guerra mundial o trataron
a ser después de héctor y tratar de
asegurar
la frontera
por lo menos hasta el nivel que pudiera
ser digamos un objetivo estratégico
llegar a ocupar el bien y quedarse con
la ucrania oriental ellos
hipotéticamente lo que parece porque
como el desplazamiento con la recolecta
lización de las tropas rusas que
salieron al frente de kiev y stern y fi
de schumi que están al norte noreste se
movieron hacia los distritos sur y
central de los distritos militares sur y
central de rusia y el empuje fíjense en
el mapa sierra por lo bueno yo los mapas
recientes que he visto la del estado de
situación de varias fuerte fuente del
ministerio defensa británico por ejemplo
del instituto para estudio de la guerra
me da la impresión que va en un
movimiento envolvente ya que fallaron en
el frente norte esa pudiera ser un
escenario y tiene lógica lo que pasa que
ahí se va a encontrar una región
densamente poblado unos ucranianos que
han hecho defensas en profundidad y se
van a encontrar las mejores fuerzas
ucranianas con lo que creo que sí le han
echado una pelea tan dura en vario full
durante una ciudad aislada ha estado
durante dos meses y pico
yo me imagino que cuando tengan que
pelear otras ciudades esto se va a
convertir en una lucha desgaste no es
cierto que los rusos son formidables por
los tanques pero los tanques en las
ciudades excepciones sus ligeras
inconvenientes en esta guerra le quiero
preguntar pablo si ese fáctico imposible
que realmente ucrania pueda
efectivamente perder territorio y que
rusia se lo anexionó como pasó con
crimea que tanto pueden resistir los
ucranianos que tanto se puede negociar
digamos ese territorio que se quiere
quedar rusia usted hablaba de esa parte
oriental de ucrania realmente esto es
posible porque además recordemos que hoy
el funcionar altos funcionarios
estadounidenses dijeron que ucrania
pudiera ganar la guerra la puede ganar
y yo lo voy yo como historiador tengo un
sano horror de hacer predicciones
pero basado en la historia también
pudiera decir
que probablemente es rusia no la gane
ahora puede quedarse como algunas
ventajas
putin combate con armamentos del siglo
21 pero tiene objetivos que están muy
bien basados en la historia y él
probablemente pudiera intentar y estoy
haciendo aquí una diferencia que asegura
en la frontera que seguros el el salar
alexei romanov en 1667 que era crear la
frontera del nieve
bueno también puede tratar de seguir a
la idea de catalina la grande que ocupar
toda la costa desde el río von
encajaría en el corredor de mar y pool
hasta el río danubio que es lo que yo
veo por las movidas por lo menos las
declaraciones que se están haciendo
sobre transnistria claro yo creo que
probablemente o no quiero no quiero otro
solar en diag ahora voy a hacer una
predicción
pero en la historia rusia ha tenido fama
de los que toman
y es posible que no logre conquistar
toda australia yo creo que los cráneos
no han demostrado una capacidad de pelea
afortunadamente nadie previó pero que
está enraizada en un pueblo que a la
hora de defenderse se defiende y
occidente
y mantiene su palabra
asumir y apoyar
yo siempre recuerdo la frase que
churchill le dijo a roosevelt
cuando los americanos no querían
intervenir les hijos dignos de los
instrumentos que nosotros terminamos la
tarea yo creo que se le inscriba por ahí
ahora de los los instrumentos y lo
haremos hasta qué punto depende de las
operaciones del compromiso usted habla
de un territorio pues que se ha vuelto
importante ya estaban las noticias estos
últimos días hablamos de transnistria en
moldavia cuál es la importancia de este
territorio porque se están produciendo
ataques
ain entre interés ministra piense qué
curioso ahora yo voy a que usted es
ratificado en la noticia de unas
explosiones sino determinadas en
edificios del gobierno entran istria
pero el el día 24 será el domingo
uno de los voceros del parlamento ruso
de la suma e hizo una declaración
diciendo que los habitantes de esa
región
eran rusos que los habitantes de ese
reunió el review podían perfectamente
estar en la misma situación que los de
lugares y donets en el año 14 al
principio no este y de los de ausencia
del sur o sea está diciendo que allí hay
una comunidad rusa que no es la mayoría
de la población pero es bastante
influyente es 30% de la población de mi
ministerio otras dniéper también se le
puede llamar
que puedes reclamar precisamente
su naturaleza de rusos para solicitar la
intervención de rusia y es cierto que el
parlamento de de transnistria que está
funcionando con un país de facto desde
el año 92
en el año 2014 pidió la elección de
rusia y rusia dejó las cosas en frío y
también dejó abierto que
si moldavia se unificaba con rumanía
transnistria podía ser reconocida por
rusia pero es curioso también que el
domingo este mismo vocero que es del
partido de putin moción y da el amigo
que
el gobierno de moldavia estaba en una
confabulación o el gobierno de rumania
para aplastar los derechos de los
habitantes de transnistria o sea que
está creando más o menos un escenario de
tipos ucraniano o criminal
ahora la cuestión es que entre las
fuerzas rusas que están en crimea que se
quieran tratar de auxiliar a sus fuerzas
que rusia tiene unidades en transnistria
a pesar que las naciones unidas y la
unión europea han pedido que se retiren
tienen fuerzas pequeñas no más allá de
un regimiento pero lo suficiente como
para ejercer autoridad o por lo menos
influencia junto con las milicias
locales en el medio entre las fuerzas de
crimea que están al este y la fuerza de
transistor ya está obesa y nikoláy es
nicoláy es que es donde los ucranianos
han hecho una resistencia feroz o sea
que entre el río dniéper claro
y el río ni esther están los ucranianos
hasta qué punto puede haber una ofensiva
en esa dirección eso puede ser un
escenario yo no creo que ahora va a ser
un escenario importante porque todo está
concentrado en el donbass pero está
abierta a la posibilidad